a little harder okay
so we are in uh somewhere outside of
hollywood where there's a lot of
entertainers and actors who get paid to
act like they're fighters and then you
have people that are
real legitimate fighters that this right
here
is weapons of mass destruction that
could hurt anybody if it hits your chin
and today we're hanging out with the man
chuck the iceman
liddell uh brother thank you for opening
your house to us
and spending this time with you oh it's
my pleasure yeah so now the one thing
most people don't know about you is the
fact that they see you as a fighter
you have to look and you look by the way
i met you a few years ago at tony
robbins event we sat right next to each
other
i would say 12 years ago 11 years ago
some over a decade ago
but uh most people see you as a fighter
people probably don't have any idea that
you have a business degree
and you got it right here from cal poly
so tell me about this whole business
degree to being a fighter i mean how
does
these two don't go together when i went
to college i would i went i wrote to
wrestle and play football
i want to get a pe degree but my grandma
didn't believe that was a real major
so i wasn't allowed to do that so i had
to pick a major when i was a freshman i
picked accounting
because i was good at it my mom used to
do bookkeeping
as an extrovert you're a numbers guy
yeah yeah my mom used to do bookkeeping
as
an extra job to make more money for the
family and uh and i used to help her out
when we were kids so i got
you know i'd help her with it so i
thought oh this is pretty easy i can do
accounting no problem
so i did accounting and then uh actually
i think i'm glad i stuck with that you
know the the business degree has helped
you know everyone asked me if i do my
own taxes and i'm like
no i had one tax i had one i have one
tax class for 10 weeks you know it's
like
that's doesn't make any sense you know
but people realize uh when you get your
accounting degree then you get your job
with the company and then
you go learn they teach you how to do
your new taxes and do
the other things you need to learn but i
think that's pretty impressive knowing
you you got yourself a degree in
accounting and you are knocking people
out and you know
oh trust me it was it was my uh
when i was given the opportunity i
that's one of the reasons i stuck it out
so long
is because it just seemed like this
would be a lot more fun than
getting a real job so so accounting
would be too boring for you
[Laughter]
today chuck liddell is doing the you
know book
keeping for this company let's look at
the highlights here i like to think
with my work ethic and the way i was
raised
that i would have excelled in anything i
did i don't think
you know i would have worked hard and i
would have i think i would have done
well doing that but i just think this
was a lot more fun
so why don't we get into that so so
let's go back to you being
12 years old 13 14. so chuck you got
brothers
you you you come from a family where you
guys you and i hear one of your brothers
is a big guy apparently six three three
hundred pounds or what do you got
yeah so were you guys i have two boys i
have a six-year-old and a four-year-old
they're always fighting were you guys
always
like was there a competition thing going
on in the family when you guys were kids
no not really like i was always uh my
mom was
your number one son i was in charge of
taking care of the kids and making sure
everyone's okay
my youngest brother who's five years
younger than me he had open heart
surgery when he was eight
and so he's always a baby like even even
later on and
when we're working at the bar so i'm
gonna go after him i mean i go nuts like
it's like
i'm like why are you protecting your
brother so crazy i'm like uh
he's still my he's still the baby my
baby brother were you fighting all the
time in school was there like a lot of
fights in school was it just the rest i
thought
i fought a lot growing up you know it
was just was just funny like i didn't
really realize i thought all the
fighters were like me growing up like
they fought a lot they came up that way
but
i've met a lot of great fighters in the
ufc that you know
been in one or two street fights in
their whole life or then
some of them have been done and i'm like
how'd that happen
i don't get it where's the inspiration
coming well now don't get me wrong i
i i was i hated bullies i didn't like
people pick on people
but i like to fight so i love testing
myself so i come up guys giving somebody
a hard time and i walk up and go hey man
you don't want to fight but i will and
when i was younger
when he said he didn't want to fight me
i'd kind of make him either put his
tail between his legs and crawl out the
door or fight me
you know i kind of learned when i was
like 21 22 i was kind of thinking
you know i never start a fight but
uh i never let you out of it real easy
either
so i kind of started learning to get
people out you know
at 21. about 21 22 i started getting it
just wasn't worth
the headache so just to kind of get an
idea from 12 to 18 how many total fights
you think you had
i couldn't talk more than 50. oh
for sure oh seriously for sure i mean we
fought
a lot i've fought a lot i've been
fighting groups and this is non-gangs
you're just talking about
that i grew up in santa barbara
california yeah there's not gonna be a
lot of gangs over there
no i mean we had some skinheads and
stuff growing up at that
at that time when i was there i just i
was like what game what
like we knew there's a couple games in
town but we were like the football
team was the gang if anything for the
wrestling team no one was afraid of
anybody else
were you the bigger guy or no when i was
15 and a half years old
i was five nine 155
15 and a half years old five nine 155
yeah and by the time i was 16 and a half
i was
62 about 180. got it so i was
i wasn't real big but i wasn't small i
was tough i mean i i just liked the
fight
and i it was entertaining it was a
competition to me did you lose any
fights in high school were there anybody
your father you like somebody caught you
or did you ever like do you
none so you don't remember ever no
no we've been in some some crazy
situations and uh you know
crazy fights brawls i got i got kicked
in the face once ran in
bunch buddy was getting jumped by about
20 guys i get kicked in the face pretty
good once but uh
you know i was still standing when they
when they were gone but
i didn't look too good at that but it
you know but still it was what it was
interesting
so did you like were you because i know
you you wrestled right so were you
planning on saying listen i have this
energy of this fire i kind of need to
compete i'm wanting to fight
were you thinking you're going to go to
boxing rock because back then there's no
ufc or you
mma oh no they don't be honest nothing
it was nothing like that i mean
first off i got started in wrestling
because i was playing football
and my football coach my sophomore year
football coach goes
oh what do you got what are you doing in
the winter well i go to i go to baseball
pre-season baseball and oh no you know
you're wrestling
okay so he kind of you have to wrestle
like
that's we had to wrestle at least for
the first part and i got into it i liked
it uh
and i did it and i did really well and
so i continued wrestling so i went on
i reason i chose cal poly was because i
wanted to do both i want to play
football
and wrestle at the same time that was
one of the few schools
that i could go do that and i would you
know i was gonna it was a division two
football school which is i had some
recruiting stuff but
i wasn't probably gonna play division
one so i went to cal poly for that
reason this is how i got into fighting
you know i did martial arts all the way
through i got my black belt in karate
and
and i was doing that when i was at
college i was in the korean martial arts
club i was in the
i jiu jitsu your fifth degree by the way
right 50 degree uh
well eight now but yeah your eighth
degree now yeah and that's
one of one of the styles but yeah that's
one of the things i try to explain to
people about my history too is like
um i used to wrestle and i go to
wrestling practice
and go to karate after that all week i
go to football go to
karate after i never took off all year
round i never i never took off karate no
matter what i was doing
i mean i missed friday nights for
football that was the
caught the night anyway so it was all
right i didn't miss any of the spying
but um but you know i was always doing
my martial arts so anyway i finished
wrestling in college and i was i was
kind of not sure what i was going to do
besides i was just going to finish up
school and figure out get a real job and
go do something and actually i met john
hackelman
at an old karate school i used to try
that what year is that
that was this was 292 maybe
got it by 92 i met went over to the
school
and sparred with john ackelman and a
ghee and we did
some wall sparring and it wasn't full
contact but it looks kind of like karate
spawning with them and
and so i'm going through this thing and
he leaves and they all take the office
yeah you kicked his ass
beat him up you know you know he did so
good i'm looking
what fight were you watching i don't
know what fight you guys were watching
but
um you fell in love now but
i'm well i was he was getting the better
of me i mean i took him down a few times
and did a couple things but
other than that he got the better of me
on everything and we weren't we just was
light contact too and i'm like
and no one's ever done that to me since
i was a kid i used to go everywhere and
beat up everybody you know whenever this
morning i was
always win so he gave me his card and i
put in my pocket and forgot about i
that that next week i was going out to
vegas to watch my buddy alfie alcarez
who used to wrestle with me at cal poly
who'd started kickboxing and he was
gonna go kick box so i'm i'm going with
him i'm at his weigh-ins
before the fight and his trainer who's
the promoter
nick guam grant uh one kick he comes
over
and goes hey chuck alfie says you're
pretty tough
you want to fight right there yeah i'm
up
sure why not what i got to do and he
goes oh you just got to come way in over
here and we're going to have you fight
so
no no it would be the next night this is
the land
guy for his main event didn't show up
for the win so
he had a guy that was 15-0 he was gonna
have me fight the guy that was 15-0
the commission goes okay so i'm weighing
in with this guy and the commission goes
so what's your record
i go i have a fire
oh no and they're like um and they they
went like they looked away from me i
looked at nick
no that's not gonna happen and uh and so
nick goes hey man
they're not gonna let it go um but if
you wanna fight
come back i'll put you on my next card
go train goldman train and come back and
oh i have you fight i got that car in my
pocket i'm like hey
this guy said kickboxing to world
champion how would you at that time
um what am i 22. okay got it
233 maybe got it and i'm like oh i see a
kickboxing world champion on there
i'm like okay let's go see this guy so i
call him up and john invites me to his
house
to train so we get up to his his gym up
on the hill
and he has a guy with him jesus sanchez
is a crowded local karate guy
coming on the watch and we put on boxing
gloves
and we'll just do some boxing spawn now
remember i've never done bought just
hands in my life
like since i started karate i've been
fighting with hands and feet i've never
done justin
i never just box this is purely hands
the feeling i'm just boxing
we start sparring and and john
hits hard if anybody that knows him
he used to find out in the jet center
and he had
a great great left hook was his license
plate
license plate great left hook so he
handed me
a beating for 19 straight minutes
jesus sanchez finally said hey man can
we stop stop hey guys come on can we
just train
stop i was like man that guy just handed
me a beating i mean yeah yeah
i didn't go down but i mean he gave me a
beating
was that the worst at that time like in
your lifetime
no one's ever been gotten anywhere near
beating me like that
before or since but um like that yeah
all right
but he's like hey so you're gonna come
back and train tomorrow right
so yeah i'll be back i was there six
days a week for the next seven years or
so before we moved to open the gym
did something like six days a week for
seven years yeah started training
started fighting and
he started helping me that's that got me
started kickboxing and that's what kept
me from
as i graduated and finished my degree
that kind of kept me like still trying
to fight i'd always wanted to
do martial arts anyway like when i was a
kid like in school i'd be
like making gyms i'd be doodling gyms
while i'm
bored in class i'd be i always wanted to
teach martial arts
i always thought i'd always be i would
have been doing martial arts and
teaching martial arts on the side did
you have an inspiration was there
somebody that you looked up to
like was there not really i i started
watching kung fu theater when i was a
kid
and they had these demonstrations in
between
like like the showings and i thought it
was the coolest thing in the world some
of the stuff these guys are doing now
find out you know it's more like the the
show
showing stuff but it still it was cool
cool enough to get me interested
a lot of people when we went to i
started learning karate my i went to an
old school
style or they they trained old school
ways which is actually really good for
my
my aed was was perfect because it
actually
trained me to control myself and be able
to do
because it's trying to you know just be
sit there in one place and do this
500 times in a row it doesn't fit your
personality was
was was tough but i wanted it so bad got
it
then i did it and it trained me to be
able to do that with other things like
be able to concentrate on a test or and
be able to focus when i need to so i'm i
got very good at focusing when i need to
and i
from and i think a lot of it's from that
style of teaching
but the one thing that i always i look
back on i look at it
is everyone you know everyone was always
looking for that magic
they were going to go to this karate
school and give this magic move and
they're going to all of a sudden be the
baddest guy on the planet most people
figure out in the first three to six
months
that that's not it it's a lot of hard
work and it's a lot
it's a lot of training it's a lot of
learning
and most people quit at that point
because they
realize there's no real magic to this
they're not gonna i'm not gonna all of a
sudden
you know turn into a wizard and be able
to beat everybody up
that's right but for me that was like oh
well that means i got to work harder
than you know i got to learn i got to be
better at this i got to get i want to
learn more
so you got the disciplines early so now
let's fast forward past that so when did
when did you meet dana white when did
that connection happen
okay dana was actually managing i think
tito and a guy by the name of managing t
yeah and wayne harriman who's friends
with tito and dan it was a friend of
mine and see me train with tito
and he actually told dana hey dana you
might want to sign this guy
he probably he might be better than tito
now so
dana signed me then and he's my manager
so he's managing me and tito
simultaneously yeah and maybe some other
people at that time me and tito used to
train together a little bit now
tito made it out to be for a long time
that like he if you listen to him it
sounded like he took me off the street
taught me how to fight and i turned on
him
from day one i was the times that i came
to work with him
i came down to help him out he was
sparring to training for a fight i'd
come down and be a farm partner
you know he's oh a truck slept on my
couch and then i'm like yeah because
you're too cheap to get me a hotel room
i slept on your couch because i'm a nice
guy i'm uh i mean
i was coming down to help you out i
wasn't you weren't helping me out
when you guys were fighting even at that
time could you were you guys
like could you hang with him at that
time he'd never been able to hang with
me that's where he left so he could
never hang with you even
though he was first hold on he couldn't
strike with me
take downs total times we've ever
trained together it's two to 16. he took
me down twice i took him down 16.
one of those i was off the mat and he
had my foot and he counted it when i was
like the end
it was entered around the other one i'd
gone out the night before in vegas and
he was training for a fight
so i was a little tired i took him down
eight times i gave him the last one like
okay whatever i'm tired i'm done no i'm
done
who's counting but he can't take me down
and then when he can start on top of me
he can't stay on top now technically
he's probably better at submitting
people than i am but other than that
there's nothing
i mean he can't he can't out position me
he can't strike me he can't out wrestle
me
and he knew this he he knew that that's
why he never wanted to fight me were you
guys like were you guys ever good
friends where you guys are best friends
i i would challenge him to tell me one
time
he called me to do something outside of
business
not to come down i call me i think once
for a charity thing he was doing at his
gym
and every other time was to to to be a
spartan partner to help him out
other than that i liked i liked some of
his friends and i didn't dislike him
either at the time but i
i didn't know him that well how much of
it let me ask you this as a fan right
i'm looking from the outset
how much of it is promotional how much
of it works none of it's promotional
definitely i'd like to believe
i'm not that's not me i've never been
that guy maybe
maybe i should have been the promotional
part of it from his end was
we're friends so i don't have to fight
him that's why i don't have to fight him
i'm not dodging him i just got it i
didn't want to fight my friend which
leads me to what he just said three days
ago
and i'm sure you saw it he said it on
tmz i didn't see it someone told him he
told me and i responded to it
so you haven't seen it yet on what he
says i don't really i don't really pay
attention to him he said some stupid
stuff over there yeah he said
he said if he wants if you want to fight
him because of money or whatever i'll do
the favor for him because he did a famer
for me and he passed
and you know what's amazing here's
what's amazing this is this is the most
amazing thing
paul knows you guys fat but paul doesn't
know when you guys professionally fought
twice
who won how many times so he doesn't
know so after
paul watches what ortiz said paul gets
the impression
that he's beaten you and then paul goes
there's a reason but i'm setting up the
punch that he's gonna give you
it's gonna be a little extra juice in it
and then paul says holy [ __ ] chuck's
kicked his ass
but tito's speaking as if he's beaten up
his entire life
so a part of him being more promotional
maybe makes the audience think that he's
got an edge over you
so what do you think about his position
and your position
i love it hey man sell it bro sell the
fight i'm
in i mean i was on the fence about
coming back and doing a comeback fight
anyway
but uh if if he'll actually fight me and
show if
if he if someone could promise me give
me some guaranteed money he's gonna show
up
i want something that says if he doesn't
show up he owes me money
well he's saying he wants to fight i
know but if he doesn't show up yeah i
know he says a lot of things
if he doesn't show up he's gonna pay me
something well fair enough maybe if he
watches this let's say
here's the other part they know why it
said in an interview they asked them
they said so they know
do you have any favorites i don't know
if you you heard what dana said they
asked them said dana do you have any
favorites he says
hell yeah i have favorites he says who
are your favorites so dana says
look the first time the chuck and him
fought
he says i told him i said chuck i want
you to beat his ass and when you do
i need the gloves and i need the trunks
cause i'm gonna frame it
he says when you come into my house
today those gloves
and the trunks are in front of his house
when you walk in he says because he
wanted you to win
so bad for whatever reason he had that
and it's amazing now you're seeing the
representation he represent
represented you and him so when you two
fight and i'm watching as a fan
you really want to beat this guy up and
win you're not just going into the
business there's a little bit of
additional juice to want to beat tito up
well for me let me let me break that
down for you the way i fight
that kind of stuff doesn't really affect
the way i fight
okay it affects the way i train he got
it you don't i don't have to get up to
train for him
i i i will never let him
have an out an inch to keep running his
mouth he runs his mouth after i've
knocked him out twice
i'd hate to see what happened if you
beat me i'd never hear the end of it
so there's no chance i'm gonna go in
there that makes sense
i'm no there's no chance i'm gonna not
gonna go in there
100 prepared for him by the way you look
like you're training you look like you
you're looking good you look very good
by the way you look like you're ready to
fight next week if there was something
i'm getting there okay but for some
reason he's thinking
chuck's been out of the game for a while
i think he's probably slipping
he probably that's the only reason he's
thinking he's gonna do it he thinks he's
got a shot at
or he really needs the money if it isn't
him who would you want to fight if it's
not him
uh well you know chael's been talking a
lot a lot of trash and i wouldn't mind
fighting jail cause
i think it's like he thinks it's funny i
keep saying that but i think it's more
of a warm-up fight for me
because he's not he doesn't hit real
hard he's not gonna
wrestle me he's not gonna grind and
bound me and he's got a big mouth
he sells fights i hate more power to you
you know
so you are you are making a comeback to
say if the right fight comes up you're
making a comeback you're you're real oh
yeah for sure
okay now you've always been peter's got
the t oh no
i haven't talked to david about it yet i
haven't talked to anybody i it just
depends i mean someone makes
it someone's gotta make a real offer you
know and that makes sense
you know but i'm not against it and but
i'm
motivated enough right now because he's
running his mouth and he it sounds like
he's serious about coming out of
retirement to fight me
then i'm gonna get in shape because
worst case scenario i'm in shape it's
okay
i don't mind i don't mind being in shape
so for other business things like
for me staying in shape is one of those
things if i want to continue to make
make money and
in the field anything that i do part of
what
my persona or my character or whatever
you want to say is
is being in shape that's right and
fitness things are where
where i can make money although the nice
thing about me is i was never a
character
it made it real easy i was just me so
let's talk about the promotional side so
you've been in it you've now 20 years
you've seen two decades right that this
has been going on with the
ufc who would you say are the biggest
[ __ ] talkers that ufc has ever had to be
honest conor
like you want to talk about backing up
and not backing up okay conor
and i've gotten a lot of [ __ ] for saying
this by from his fans
like i don't like that kind of [ __ ]
talking i don't like that kind of thing
i really that's not my style i guess the
wind and he does the chicken dance you
know what i mean
as you can tell by looking at this fine
physique that i'm a freak of nature and
i'm i'm a specimen of human movement so
who the [ __ ]
i look at him as a novice he he throws
an overhand right he looks at the floor
closes his eyes and hopes for the best
this is this is day one beginner stuff
where i come from
you're making better than half a million
i gave you notice 48 000 you went from
but you went from 48 000 to half a
million wow
thank me and be grateful be great i
butchered your face
then they'll put that at the quote chuck
doesn't like the way he talks like
but i go you obviously didn't read the
article i also said he's one of my
five top favorite guys to watch fight
right now as i've also said
good thing great a lot of great things
about it that was the only thing i said
i don't like the way you talk [ __ ]
but i get it he's trying to get in your
head
he has purpose to [ __ ] talking which i
love
i actually love that mind warfare
because when i'd say stuff
anything i say that was a little bit
[ __ ] talking at all and things was me
trying to get in someone else's
the other guy's head you know you might
see some groundwork but that that's
what like i always fight if it comes it
comes but i'm planning on standing up
with him and knocking him out
hopefully like if i'm fighting keto i'd
i'd give him a [ __ ] about if he's
if he's go off he's a man he'll stand up
with me because i want him to think
about maybe i have to stand up with him
to show that i can fight
you know so i you know so he's not
trying to take me down the whole time
conor does a massive job of it i think
that's how he that's one of the reasons
to beat aldo first
i watch aldo fight all the time i've
never seen him run across a ring and try
to
attack somebody he's he's a all kind of
muay thai type guy he he tries to feel
you out for a round or so and then
figures out your timing and then goes
after you you know so
i think he was so mad he ran across the
ring eight seconds whatever the time was
but but conor's one of those [ __ ]
talkers that he delivers he fights the
way he talks like he
he fights with reckless abandon would
you say tito
delivers or not tito did a really good
job
of delivering when he was fighting
guys that delivering in impressive
fashion
when he was fighting guys that were
lower than them
that weren't quite his level but then
like i remember
watching a thing on the best dance floor
show i think it was with him and randy
couture
and randy just and randy's a good [ __ ]
talker
like a counter puncher with a [ __ ]
talking i mean he was making
tio look stupid
he got off the screen you put him as one
the best couture
he's good at counter like he's a great
but he's like like a lot of wrestlers
are a lot of guys have a good
i do that same thing like i'm kind of
like more of a counter
punch guy like if you say something i'll
keep taking it for a little bit then
i'll
say something that trumps whatever you
were saying ron rousey
did a great job i mean she was promote
see and and those people
like chill sauna does a great job of
promoting i think it's wwe and i think
it's stupid the way he does stuff
but i know fans that just love it not
not the hardcore fans the other fans the
guys that
occasionally watch that that they touch
and that's that's what makes those guys
important so much bigger
pulling an audience that you don't
already have they're they pull in
people that don't always watch this got
it very cool
so so let me ask you this your favorite
fighters i know you've said good things
about the diaz brothers
who do you enjoy a watch and fight
you know i like watching guys that they
get after and try to finish fights
to be honest i just like guys to fight
like show up to fight like this isn't a
game they're not trying to win by points
they're not trying to
they're not trying to protect their
career you're getting a little bit of
that recently where guys are trying to
win with nothing
well and don't get me wrong i understand
from a coaching standpoint i remember
telling one of my guys
that he was fighting and he took this
guy down
five times and went first and went for a
submission right away and got rolled
over
all five times so he was losing the
fight because he's in a bad position
even though he got the takedown
he he only got reversed because he went
for a submission
but regular refs regular judges don't
understand that
i'm like look you have to when you take
him down
you got to hold him for a few minutes
hit him a couple of times hold him for a
little bit hit him a couple times then
go for your submission don't jump right
away
you know which is not the way i really
want as a fan would want to watch why i
like the way he fought
as a fan so you're giving technical
advice as a coach but as a fan you don't
want to see them fight the way you give
the technical advice
right how interesting is that people ask
me the question i ask oh this is a coach
manager
good point that's a cool job as a coach
manager i don't want you to lose a fight
because that costs you
that cost you money now don't get me
wrong
being an exciting fighter helps too it's
going to get you a lot more money if
you're winning no doubt about it
i'm assuming you were federal would like
you would enjoy watching fedor fight oh
i love watching fedor fight yeah
he didn't have to fight at any time dan
henderson
i love watching him fight that guy's
he's a beast and and you know
he's never out he's never out of the
fight you know
he can fit he can win you can beat him
up for four rounds and
four four minutes and 45 seconds in a
fifth round if he if he catches one of
those bombs
it's it's good night why don't we talk
about that so when you're in it like the
the thing i'm curious about is
how much of this like you're in it it's
heated you're just going bam bam you're
throwing the punches at them
you're throwing the knees and you're
getting kid let's say someone's on you
and they're hitting you do you actually
know what's going on those are purely
reflexive like can you
are you able to in that split second can
you process what you're doing
you know what's going on your process
how much is processing how much is
reflexive
usually like in it like when you get in
an exchange the fast exchange
like if we get in boom we get something
we start faster it's it's reaction your
reaction got it you're acting fast
um with someone on top pounding on you
and you're down and that's thinking
you can see it coming it's taking that's
not a quick
like in exchange i mean like someone
throws something you counter
and then you count it and then
then you start thinking again i mean it
just it's it's a quick
it's really quick the those little quick
reaction moves
and in that moment in that moment like
when i thought what i fought vidor
belford
he finally came after me in the third
round because they're telling me he had
to win the round and came at me
and i sat him on his ass with a right
hand
that was just a counter i just i was i
was reacting to him coming straight that
means to step up
that was just something that that went
through and did i mean
you have one the best knockouts of all
time you if you want to watch the
highlights knockout highlights just type
in chuck liddell knockout highlights
it's non-stop you can watch them and
they're
incredible but but the thing i want to
know about like in the business world
sometimes in the business world you get
hit
okay and in that moment you can't you
can't
teach a dog fight to somebody if you got
the fight you got the fight
sometimes you see in your world somebody
gets hit
and they back down and back up and they
don't come back to fight
is that instinct is that uh fear is that
the
not lack of dog fight do you see that as
a coach or something
all the time okay i say this all the
time with striking
like i'll say that guy doesn't like to
get hit everyone goes what do you mean
no one likes to get it yep yeah no what
i better what i mean by that
is he's unnecessarily afraid of getting
hit
he's pulling his head out like this he's
not reacting the way he can be changed
i you know from your years of watching a
bunch of fighters
can that actually be changed for
somebody i've never tried to change that
i mean it's a funny question because i
used to always think mental toughness
you either have it or you don't but i
did a lot of studying on
on on teaching it and you know i think
part of it was for me i just when it
came to me by the time it came to me if
you weren't mentally tough i didn't want
to
i it's too late i don't want to i'm not
i'm not going to waste my time trying to
teach you how to be tough
so i guess the question will be more
this way go back to when you were in
high school where a guy was maybe at
your level or college where you were
competing and you said this guy's
actually
he's pretty solid when i fight this guy
but his mental and emotional toughness
was a little bit less than yours
did you see somebody like they said that
guy never made it past a certain level
and you kept continuing
to grow oh for sure when you put under
that pressure you have
you know two two choices where you break
and fold
or you come out fighting if you're gonna
succeed and i think about anything
you need to be that guy that comes out
fighting tito tapped his strikes
one time a funny story so we were at a
party talking about it
and i forgot that he attacked the
strikes with when he fought frank
shamrock
we were talking about this other guy
that tapped to
battery silva and i was like to strike
he was getting struck and he attacked
i'm like yeah i'm a what a [ __ ]
man can you believe that guy's tapped
his strikes if i can think if you can
think the tap
you can think to defend yourself and try
to get out of it can't you
i
[Laughter]
in that fight because you know when they
stopped that fight i went nuts because i
would
that was right when i first started
training was helping him
train get ready for fight was before he
fought frank shamrock and i was on the
side and i didn't see him tap
i went nuts if they stopped the fight
but no no it's almost over he had he
already won he was one other he won the
rounds up to then
and then that round was almost over i'm
like oh no no no he can't stop the fight
why are you stopping he's not hurt
but then i sometimes he tapped
he tapped how have you ever tapped
no no no wait no here's the thing now
don't get me wrong i'm not telling
people not to exactly but
but the point i'm making with you is
you've been hit i mean you you will not
stop with the fight till the very end
oh no i i went to sleep the guy tried to
try to choke me i
went to sleep um i i don't
know here's the thing though don't get
me wrong now tapping is okay it's not
it's not if you get in a position where
your arm is going to get broken your
knee is going to get broken better
smarter side of valor
uh live to fight another day you blow
out your knee
it might never be the same you bought
your elbow it might never be the same
so that's something to tap to the thing
is what like the chokes like when a guy
taps to a choke if i can think the tap
i can think to try to get out of it i
still got a little bit of air left like
wow
i've i've rolled out of i've rolled out
of headlocks when
in high school wrestling or a guy who
rolled out the wrong way
got out stood up like this
stars in my eyes could barely see but
they didn't know
they had no idea but i rolled out and i
almost choked myself out but i got out
wow for me it's never been a question
whether or not
i'm gonna quit i have my saying about
mental toughness i always said mental
toughness is an everyday thing
you can't just turn it on and off for a
fight for a match for whatever
it's life it's life you have to do it
all the time and and as i read
studies on it actually afterwards
training people to do it a lot of
teaching them routines helps anything
where you have to do it all the time and
it's just a you're not
when you don't feel like doing it you
get up and do it because that's your
routine
it almost doesn't make you think it's
continuous yeah and
and the point i'm getting to is i was it
was probably i've been retired for about
three probably three years and i've been
kind of letting things go
and hey man i don't have to do that now
i put in my time
i did my thing i i became world champion
i was doing everything i wanted to do i
can relax i don't have to do this i
don't have to do that
uh i don't feel like doing that today
that kind of stuff i started doing that
and then we're in hawaii
my family and my oldest son
starts running up the mountain we're
going up on the
on the stairs it starts running up and i
start running up behind him
because i'm not i cannot use that so i
i'm running up and i pass him and i
realized
i'm in not very good shape if i pass him
and and he's going to stop but i'm like
man i started running this thing i got
to finish it
and i started in my mind for the first
time in my life that i could remember
i actually questioned whether or not i
should
and for me that was enough just the fact
that the question even came into my mind
whether or not i should stop or keep
going bothered me
and made me start working on changing
back my decisions
in my normal everyday life because
i it was bleeding into my competitive
life
even if it's just that kind of
competition
was the fact that the fact that because
i've never even it that the question
never was
for me the question would have never
came up if i started running that i'm
gonna finish it do you think success
caused that
lit a little bit i i don't think it was
success i think it was retirement
it was actually just because for me you
reach the top of the mountain type of
feeling
well and being like i felt like when i
retired i was done
i didn't have i lost that even being at
the top of the mountain
i still was trying to prove i'm the best
in the world all the time
so there's still that goal was always
right there it's always been there
and all of a sudden i move on from here
there's no goal there's no there was no
final place was a retirement
psychologically messing with you like
what am i going to do today when i wake
up like was there like a what
was there part of that that screwed with
your head a little bit or no i don't
know that it screwed with my i mean
it is a really weird thing
to do like you've been getting ready for
the next thing
for since since i was you know 12 years
old
10 years old i've been doing that's what
i'm saying i haven't get ready for a
football game
wrestling matches yeah all of a sudden
and then
you know and now i don't have to get
ready for anything
i don't have to do anything all right
because i used to say i say oh i take
all this time off taking up time off
taking time off for me used to be still
going to gym five days a week and
working out with the team
you know still going going to lift in
four four days a week you know
it was still quite a bit working out and
i used to call that
taking time off but you know oh yeah i'm
out of shape because i have been taking
time off
well no i just wasn't in peak shape but
i was still in shape but now i was like
oh now i don't have to do anything
and you know then you start prioritizing
other things like you know i got oh i
get to do this for kids i can do that
it takes interesting presidents yeah and
the only reason i asked that is because
you hear a lot of times guys that say i
was with jean lucavac a couple weeks ago
john lucavac
is uh they call him the most interesting
man in the world guys got like 12 000 12
million followers on
uh instagram he runs a three billion
dollar company 300 400 million
dollar guy and he said i ran so hard
from 25 to 35 that i stopped
and he says when i stopped it was kind
of like what am i going to be doing he
was having you know health issues and
all these other things
so sometimes you hear stories i'm going
to be a millionaire with the moment i
become worth 10 million dollars
i'm gonna retire and then when they do
retire it's like a feeling of emptiness
sometimes you get super competitive
people that get
if they don't have something they're
gonna be doing next and that kind of
leads me into the next thing
so you know you see in in basketball
chuck retires he comes because he
becomes an announcer
you know shaq retires he's an announcer
this other guy retires you either become
a coach or
trainer or all this that's what you do
in your world when someone retires
what do you do next well i mean you can
become an announcer i mean that's
possible that's
that's that option is there for me being
a coach for me the reason that's not an
option for me is that i have a family
and i don't
and it's it's very time intensive but
i've started doing
you know other things and i i found that
i needed to start by
finding something i'm passionate about i
need to start i mean i started acting i
started trying to i'm trying to learn
how to act better and do better in
movies and
you've been able to give me quite a few
things
yo move the car he's drama that's
chuckled down what's your chocolate
dough
guy's the ultimate fighting champ they
call him the iceman he ko'd randy
couture twice last year
i'm giving him the spot out of respect
don't be a schmuck turtle
the dell's the gut you think yeah no
doubt
check out the hidden camera van parked
conveniently right next to the empty
spot
i don't see any cameras drama they're in
there turtle trust me
they're in there look buddy i was here
first
i don't think so that spot's ours so why
don't you and your hooptie just move
along
oh what you're hoopty you're beater
you're hunk of junk
oh below you should watch who you're
talking to like that my friend i ain't
your friend tough guy
yeah that's right i know who you are you
wwf
wannabe so you gonna move your car what
do i gotta get in that movie for you
daddy doing a few things i got i got a
bigger roll coming up
soon um anything you can talk about or
now you've got no not yet uh
that's how you're gonna sign yeah but
we've got a few things uh coming up that
should be coming out soon
so you're keeping yourself busy i'm
kidding is that everybody is it a lot of
your peers as well like
you know because because remember back
in the days remember back in the days
when
the biggest controversy was hey ufc
fighters
don't make any money and there was this
whole everybody would question dana no
one's making money no one's making money
no one's making money
and then a little bit what is the career
maybe not for guy at your level what is
the career for the other guys that are
fighting is it just purely going into
that coaching route or
is it is the money now here where cats
can actually start making some money
sponsorships all this other stuff
i haven't i've been out of the market
for long enough where i'm not sure where
they're at right now i mean i know some
of the guys they're they're getting paid
better i mean i still think you have to
there's not a lot of guys making enough
money to
retire on for the rest of their life
they have to have to build something
to go go to from there but most guys i
think that are
i always look at the coaching route it's
always a good one i mean
i i would have been okay with that if
that was my
that's what i ended up doing because
that's what i wanted to do since i was a
kid
was to teach karate like i want to do if
i do it i'll probably do more of a
karate school than a team fight team i i
want to i i'm actually
we're still planning on i'm going to
open one but we're going to have it's
more
going to be more of a karate school it
might have a fight team
as long as they understand i'm not their
coach i will help them
as much as they're here but i don't want
to be their coach
and the hard thing with that is it
becomes they become family
you know you've got guys if i'm coaching
i had a fight team when i was fighting
and you got 15 20 guys fighting and
they become family you know and so if i
feel like
me being there when they're fighting
would help their
them a better chance of winning i feel
like i have to be there
so you know and with now they're being
four ufc's a year
you know more i would be gone if i had
20 guys i'll be gone
i'll be going on 40 weeks a year you
know that's the family because without
without
bellator a bunch of other organizations
that are out there that are great right
now
so you are saying there's more money to
be made today than what it was 10 15
years ago
night and day just what it is today so
dana white he seems like a very
interesting guy
what would you say are some of dana's
strengths passion he wanted this
sport to succeed i think what him and
lorenzo did really well is
their decisions were made on not trying
to make
as much money as they can this fight it
was how can we grow the brand
how can we grow the sport yep how big
can we make this sport and obviously
they cashed out on that one pretty good
yes they did um four billion or whatever
the number was as mad as anyone wants to
get at them and all that stuff with it
is
you got to remember hey man if they
didn't come around
and sink you know frank and lorenzo and
dana had to come around and those guys
hadn't sent
46 million into trying to make a sport
work
we'd never be here was it every time
where you guys were almost out of
business
was it every time it was like they they
actually i think the ultimate fighter
was kind of
the way i understood it i'm not not i
really tried to think i have insight on
this no one ever said it but
i heard from other people that they were
thinking about if that one didn't work
if that didn't do it they're gonna wrap
it up they were gonna
you know moving out after that and
obviously
it was a home run and it's that big of
an enterprise now oh but and
and it couldn't have been better they
they they paid it out of pocket so
they owned it you know which means you
get a bigger brand
which means they got they've got this
franchise that they could move around
they can do whatever they want
well dana's equity alone is getting them
360 million somewhere you know
it's a solid number oh so last question
for you last question for you
you saw the connor mayweather fight so
let's talk about boxers
in the ufc world ufc boxing world
okay i hear i've been hearing this for a
while i don't
the mayweather they're talking about him
fighting in the ufc
i i don't know what guy they're going to
bring over to give him even have a shot
at making it out of the first round it's
going to be someone that doesn't belong
in the ufc
if they want to give conor i mean give
mayweather a chance
and then someone said that they're
talking about conor fighting them in the
ufc
which is again it'll be embarrassing
for me what would be fun was to see them
kickbox
have connor and mayweather kickbox
because i just want to watch
mayweather get hit with two leg kicks
and be
laying in the corner crying for his
mommy i mean
how long would it take 10 seconds it's
done look he's got it's like
in mma he's got one punch and he's not a
heavy puncher
he's not known for his heavy hands he's
got one punch
to knock the guy out and then it's over
as soon as a guy grabs a hold of him
it is over kickboxing i mean he's got
one round maybe
to knock the guy out because he won't be
able to stand after
if i i mean if i fought a boxer in a
boxing stance stands in a boxing stance
he's not gonna even if he was taught to
leg check
he's gonna like check my shin once
then he's going to stop leg checking it
and then he's not going to be able to
walk
the leg kicks alone
they they don't know how to defend him
they're not used to getting hit by him
i mean i had a cut on my [ __ ] and they
took an x-ray
and the doctor came out and had to show
my wife how crazy the x-ray was because
i had an extra layer of bone all the way
down my shin
she's like man what kind of trauma have
you had in your shin i have an extra
layer of bone always all the way down
but that's the difference you know if i
kick someone that doesn't
he hasn't trained and hasn't kicked very
hard it's not going to hurt me it's
going to hurt them a lot
wow an extra layer of bone you're going
to get it
by uh uh this has been good but i i got
a question for you here
our guy paul here our camera guy paul
you know he likes to brag about the fact
that he's never been knocked out before
and you know he started he's i'm not
gonna say what he said he started
talking a lot of smack about you
i'm not gonna go
did you see that ultimate fighter where
the kid was saying he'd never been
knocked out to the bigger guy
no and he had him in the in the house
had him punch him
and then was talking about it afterwards
well i'm sure we're going to find that
that clip to show it
i can't i can't i can take anything you
can
and i will do this do it just do it
[Music]
do it
paul went about some gear and he brought
ivan drago's outfit you know from rocky
but
i'm just curious to know what a person
who's not in the world
who is willing to take a punch from you
what it's going to look like so you
might like
giving a shot to paul and see what he
says he played football he's got a
strong neck
he tells me he's got an 18-inch neck so
that's awesome paul you up for it
the neck will help at least i won't hurt
his neck
but brother thank you so much for your
time i really enjoyed it
[Music]
a little harder okay
uh
[Music]
oh